where exactly did the critical race
theory movement originate
well the debunk 1619 project from nicole
hannah jones was published in august of
2019
inspiring teachers to become activists
and turn their kids their students into
agitators
a presentation delivered a few months
after that by then president of the
national council for social studies tina
heafner
in it she laid the groundwork for an
overhaul
she said social studies can be an
educational space
to teach anti-racism to confront the
history of racist ideas associated
with harmful social economic cultural
and political disparities
and to champion human rights and
anti-racist policies
well just a few months later in front of
the american historical association she
went
further the social studies in curriculum
has
we have been in the last decade
or two decades at a critical juncture of
really recognizing the need to
teach critical history it's also really
critical
that we begin to introduce a lot of the
understandings of the systemic
structures
that we have in place and in
understanding that our role as social
studies educators
become really important because the
narratives we teach we often
expose students to white exceptionalism
you're always smarter with glasses right
come on joining us now dr ben carson
former hud secretary founder of american
concert
cornerstone institute dr carson um
we can now see where this clear line uh
where social studies became
social activism or a vehicle for it
your reaction well in fact uh
this tina li hefner
says that they have action civics now
and associates that with critical race
theory in which
they abandoned all thoughts of political
neutrality
which used to characterize public
education
and have wantonly decided that they want
to
indoctrinate people according to their
belief system
and of course this is extremely
detrimental
now uh you know some of them claim that
this is not
actually being taught in schools and
grade schools or high schools
it's only being taught in law schools
clearly that is not the case
and that's why so many of the parent
groups are upset
and this is actually a good thing a good
thing that they're pushing it so hard
that it's actually waking people up
before it was sort of like
simmering slowly in a saucepan and the
frog gets cooked but now they turn the
heat up too high and
people are waking up very quickly which
is a good thing
and you know the american people are a
lot smarter
than many on the left given credit for
well we reached out
yeah we reached out to ms hefner by the
way dr carson who told us in quite a
long
communication civics in history have
been neglected for decades due to other
testing and curricular priorities driven
by standardization accountability
there is a common agreement that
students need greater access and
exposure to civics in history middle and
high school
as well as deep rich content that offers
a diverse
equitable and inclusive narrative
there's that dei
dr carson uh diverse diversity equity
and inclusion
um inform us we
we have plenty of equity and inclusion
in our society
it really kind of depends on how you
want to look at things
the glass half empty of the glass has
full when you look at the tremendous
progress that has been made
by minorities in this country over the
last
50 years it's astonishing and
you know trying to relate everything
back to slavery
think about the fact that slavery has
been parts of society since the
beginning of civilization
and there are more slaves today than
there were in 1863 when the emancipation
proclamation
and we fought a war to get rid of it
think about it
dr carson this is stunning but now we
see the roots of crt